the phones are open at Triple Eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
eight did you notice this shows on the
air
we're not shut down but we don't have
any debt and we have savings and we live
within our means so we're here today to
help you and we're gonna continue to do
that
the phone lines work the electricity is
on it's not a miracle it's a
mathematical process it's called a
budget it's called living on less than
you make and staying out of debt it
stabilizes your life stabilizes your
business oh and by the way it would
stabilize your country if you could get
around to it and you wouldn't be shut
down very sad day for those of you that
work for the federal government and I am
going to do anything I can to help you
because I know a lot of you were scared
and a lot of you were struggling what
are you gonna do because your paycheck
just got shut off and you know poking
fun at you or picking on you in some
ways and not something we're gonna do
here we're gonna help you because a lot
of you are in messed up situation and
the longer this goes a little harder
it's gonna be on you I hope for the sake
of the federal government employee that
it doesn't go very long you know just as
a person person-to-person kind of a
comment and but you know I will tell you
this let's say you know it runs out to
whatever Friday or something and then
then you go back to work and it really
mathematical he's not gonna have a ton
of effect on your life all it did scare
the crap out of you and I'll tell you
that could be a good thing for you cuz
it could you know one federal government
employee tweeted this morning that he
was completely debt free house and
everything has this emergency fund in
place and so not happy about being shut
down and shut out but not panicking
because he's in good shape why cuz
decided to get in good shape a few years
ago so maybe this becomes your
call for some of you that you I mean
I've had bad things happened to me and
it became my wake-up call and so that's
not to pick on you that's just to say
there's some good that can come out of
this especially if it's just a little
short that blip and then boom you're
right back to work and then you know you
go wow that's scared the crap out of me
I don't ever want to be there again I'm
gonna get out of debt I'm gonna have an
emergency fund I'm gonna live on less
than I make I'm gonna live on a budget
so if this uh continued problem with the
government then I'm not gonna get in a
mess that I can't survive because I you
know the thing might be longer next time
and I don't know how long it's gonna be
this time I don't have any idea but I do
know when you do know that that that is
this thing in this problem with people
not doing meth in Washington DC is
really is coming to a head now and I I I
hope that we the people all of us
experienced enough pain that we look at
this and we say you know there's a lot
of things that government is trying to
do that are good things it usually does
them poorly but they're trying to do
some good things that doesn't matter if
you can't afford it if you get paid on
Friday and you take all of your money
and you give it to a person who's
struggling and hurting because you're a
sweetheart a person and then next week
your car gets repo'd means you helped
somebody but you couldn't afford to help
somebody and that's really where the
federal government budget is at this
stage of the game well we have a moral
obligation I don't give a rip about your
moral obligation I mean you can be a
liberal you meet conservative but you're
not exempt from math in either case you
can be a Democrat or a Republican but
you're not exempt from math well the
government will the government the
government is not infinite there's a
tipping point in the math and we're
approaching it and these kinds of things
are going to happen more and more and
more it's going to become more and more
unstable as the overspending and the
increase in the debt can
and I kind of thought maybe this was
just a and it may be for some of the
Republicans a strategic chess move to
throw the Obamacare discussion in there
but really when you look at Obamacare
which went into force today the truth is
is that you are either going to have
your employer pay for your health care
or you are going to go to one of the
exchanges and receive a generic
substandard government program or you're
gonna buy in the open market now in the
open market as of January 1st all health
insurance companies are required to
accept everyone regardless of
pre-existing conditions now surely you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
realize that when your health insurance
company now has to take people that have
three months to live with cancer they
now have to take people who have had
seven heart attacks they now have to
take people who whatever the health
indicator is of extreme expense and they
have to take them one of two things is
going to occur mathematically with your
health insurance company either it's
going to go broke or they're going to
double your premiums because they have
to pay for all that crap again this
isn't a political thing it's a math
thing and the problem is is that in the
name of doing something that someone
believed it was a moral initiative or a
moral imperative that people quit doing
math and that's really on both sides of
the aisle but in this case it's the
president and I appreciate that he has a
heart to help hurting people I hope that
that's at the center of this I don't
know if it is I don't know him but that
doesn't even matter well what about the
people who can't get health care Dave
it's just unfair I understand but what
you're going to do here is you are in
order to fix that problem you're going
to break the existing health care system
and if the goal is to nationalize health
care and completely socialize it I think
this will do it
I don't think any I don't think any the
existing healthcare companies are
probably gonna the health insurance
companies are going to survive long term
under this because they're forced to
take anybody and everybody and they're
forced to compete with a government
program that's substandard and so you
can buy a nice home in other words but
now you're gonna pay double for it or
you can live in government subsidized
housing or your employer is going to
furnish your housing this is the new
housing program they just came out with
it sounds a lot like communism really at
its core because now you are told that
you will buy health insurance or you
will be given a penalty you will buy
health insurance it is mandatory the
government has now mandated it now I
think buying health insurance is a
really good idea but the lack of freedom
and the forced the the level of force
that is in this thing is absolutely
amazing so it is part of the government
shutdown discussion it wasn't just a
tactical move because it's so freakin
expensive and we really do have to stop
spending money we don't have meantime if
you're a federal government employee and
you need some help some advice that is
you give me a yell I'll help you any way
I can because I know you're scared
you're hurting today and hopefully this
will be short for your sake and it'll be
your wake-up call where you're never
facing this again
you